damnit live oh my god you just saved my
life
how could I ever thank you just don't
wait to live your life go do it now oh
hi I'm Meghan and recently I completed
some stuff off my bucket list and now I
just want to give other people the
opportunity to do the same thing this
week we're gonna hang out with Jasmine
Robbins she's a video producer here at
BuzzFeed and one of the most confident
bold people that I know so if you had to
do three things off of your bucket list
what would they be one do a completely
naked photo show I've never done that
before and I really think it would be
pushing myself I want to be tattooed by
a woman because I have so many like
empowerment tattoos but none of them
have been by women I also want to
inspire people like face to face to do
something off their bucket list I mean I
think we can make that happen if you're
free this week I think I can make
sometime okay great let's do it sure why
is this on your bucket list
I'm always someone who's like be
yourself be you no matter what you know
and I think I show that often but I've
never really pushed myself to the
extreme
I want to look fashionable relaxed and
still myself I want it to be quirky I
want it to be a little like rough like
my body is not like the ideal body for
other people but it's the ideal for me
so when I like go to photo shoots I'm
used to putting my body in a way that
looks flattering and this I don't
necessarily want it to look flattering I
just want it to look like comfortable in
me some poses aren't gonna look the most
flattering but they're gonna look the
most real and that's what I want to
protract
[Music]
I just got the photos I'm a little
scared
chance nude it's called jazz nude oh I
love this picture of me sitting in this
chair but I really like the ones with
nothing on this is just me the pictures
with debris in the fern
fire this is truly like what I wanted to
do I'm excited it's tattoo time so jazz
doesn't know that I sent ahead a picture
from her photo shoot to the tattoo
artist Zoey and Zoey has drawn up a
tattoo for jazz with that nude photo as
inspiration and hopefully she likes it
because it's going on her body forever
why is this on your bucket list I have
so many tattoos that have to do with
like being a powerful woman and just
being empowered in general there's
always been just a little missing link
that none of my female empowerment
tattoos have been from a woman so like
having a boss ass woman give me a boss
ass tattoo would just be awesome do you
have any idea what you're gonna get I
have no idea at all I have an idea I
sent ahead a picture from your new photo
shoot - Zoey are you ready to see it
you're kind of freaking out I'm kind of
sweating but sure it's gonna be great
I love her I truly love this I like the
thickness it's an empowering like stamps
yay let's put it on you forever yeah I
[Music]
love it this is exactly what I wanted
it's clean it's simple but it reminds me
a message of like loving and
appreciating every part of yourself and
this is exactly what I wanted to go
along with this arm so today we're
hitting the streets of Hollywood so jazz
can ask other people what's on their
bucket list so jazz why is this the
final thing on your bucket list because
of this I become really inspired and I
feel like me meeting people face-to-face
and inspiring them to do something on
their bucket list will be awesome all
right I'm out here on the corner and I'm
realizing how much I hate approaching
people yeah you want to come be in a vid
yeah I really hate Afro shoot
[Music]
[Music]
hi what's your name Joe what do you want
to do before you die
I want to make people off
[Music]
to create a feature-length film oh okay
go ahead and write it down wherever you
can
[Music]
a lot of people put some like really big
picture Gold's on here it was good I
feel good about that lunch yeah honestly
this whole process has like made me
think of future stuff more there's so
much I want to do so yeah I think I'm
gonna like keep on pushing for like my
goals and my dreams it was just like a
whole new point of empowerment for
myself who's next
I'm not sure who is next let us know
below in the comments when I'll get some
ice cream I want sushi so different
[Music]